even men you know get excited sure sure
I can't I know you can you just did I
did there it is
you think too little of you sir oh you
think you see through me do you what you
don't but I see through you assuming
your mom and your sister were like okay
you're working with Benedict can you get
us on set honey jam was that I do like
the Cumberbatch yes I mean a lot of
women were picking my brain they weren't
about us they were about you not only
about me see everything now Benedict is
a very talented actor as we all know but
he also seems to have a jokester side to
him is that a parent on on set yeah yeah
he keeps it very light and run and he's
got that great British wit and you know
sense of humor he that he kind of gets
for free but yeah he I mean we had some
really intense you know emotional themes
and and he always found the levity in it
there's a great gag reel that's coming
out that [ __ ] and we'll show you that
side of Benedict better than I could
probably describe it you can't tell
Rachel McAdams couldn't be any happier
to be part of the Marvel family joining
a franchise that is known for a hit
after hit but really it comes naturally
to Rachel from the notebook to Mean
Girls she's used to success which means
constantly addressing rumors Mean Girls
musical we read that you would like to
partake in this someday this project a
lot of movies are getting turned into
musicals we're seeing it on TV on the
big screen
was this a joke that you were chatting
about or well I mean I'm not I'm not I'm
not super musical I guess I can I can
pretend to be but if there's like an
ice-skating okay part of it stars on ice
where's my Disney are
yes we could have remain cross version
of that maybe that is so fetch Gretchen
stop trying to make fetch happen it's
not going to happen